[Music]
we've come
to talk to you again because i'm sitting
here with my friend billy
and later on we'll get quite silly
and the podcast that you're listening to
is fun it's very fun
it's the sound of the friendship onion
simon garfunkel eat your heart out hello
guys hello
which oh that's a tough question you
know because i think they both
have some real brilliance about them
yeah they do
you have a much more refined singing
voice than me
which puts you in the art gar phone call
place but then you're also
a great songwriter which puts you in the
paul simon place
so i think i just both of them you're
both
and i'm like a jilted lover no you've
let yourself down there
my favorite thing is what's the album
where paul simon
is in front of garfunkel yeah we talked
about this didn't we it's
uh the weather on the street together
yeah is it bridge over troubled news
maybe bridge over trouble and if you put
your thumb
over paul simon's face try this at home
please
then it looks like art garfunkel has a
really long mistake
brilliant here's something to do at home
welcome to the friendship
welcome to the friendship onion you guys
hope everything's going well i have a
question for you right off the bat
because i've been struggling with this
all week and um
i wondered if you knew you know when you
see a
big truck or lorry for people
in in britain back home driving on the
street very often they're not driving on
all their wheels
sometimes a pair of wheels will be
elevated oh yeah
when would you put those other wheels
down i think i know the answer to this
dumb
when you put a weight into the back so
say he was collecting sand
from a building site he
he puts in you know three tons
of sand we'll need more wheels or we're
going to burst the ones we've got
ah it's a weight-bearing thing yeah a
load bearing yeah
right okay well great i think that's a
great answer that was my that was my
burning question
for the day well that's a great way to
start this week and this week is a very
exciting week
tom because we've got a fantastic guest
on
yes tell them tell them you sure you
don't want to tell them
why don't i do the first word and you do
the last one all right
stephen colbert stephen colbert who we
were lucky enough to go
and visit him in new york and do his
show which you can find on youtube and
we had a fantastic time
and during the show billy said will you
do our podcast and stephen said yes
and he is a man of his word and he's
coming on today and i think he's quite
angry with me
because i i think i'm the first person
to stump him
with a lord of rings question yes yes
um where in fangun forest
do the ants hold their
intimate that's easy it's doing dingo
you got it
easy i mean i don't i don't know why
it's only it's only easy when you know
the answer and uh billy and i have
talked about this before we think that
probably that question was so astute
because why would you need to remember
that answer it's a throwaway answer yeah
you're very smart when you think about
it i am quite smart but it's
way way deep deep in my brain my
smartness yeah we'll show you keep the
other stuff at the surface
you keep more of the whimsy up top and
the real genius sits down in your gut
yeah but i've seen it i've spied it and
it's yeah well should we get stephen on
why wouldn't we stephen colbert
you've joined us on our podcast and we
could not be happier
you're a man of your word stephen which
is great you said it on the show and
billy and i thought
wow we've goosed him because he said it
on tv we've got him but you've actually
come through
yeah we didn't think you would come no
that was sometimes it's it's what i call
a tv yes
someone will ask me to do something but
i'll say on tv i'll say that's a tv yes
but we were just talking about that
there's some parts of america
that uh people will just say yes to make
you feel better that they haven't said
no
and some of our listeners were saying
minnesota
are well known for that they're very
nice
they're something called minnesota nice
there you go that's what they were
talking about we're talking about
well we thought you were being minnesota
nice yeah and i actually
i'm not that nice i got caught which is
fine i totally embraced it but i got
caught in in a kind of
tv yes or a filmic yes from peter
jackson i don't know if you know this
story i think you were there that night
right but the night that lord the rings
won did the q
the clean sweep of oscars we then went
to
the one ring party yep and you sang and
i
sang and everyone was up on stage and
pete jackson
pulled me up on stage and said
there is a prank that dom plays on
elijah wood
that we're hoping to put in the dvd and
asked me then
on stage in front of like 3 000 people
will you give us permission to do it
because i guess
i might have been able to say well no
i'm going to block that ah so i went uh
yeah great which i would have done
anyway and he did the same to mark
odesky that night
because he said where is going to be the
next big lord rings party
and odeski went welling to new zealand
so he's a smart man yeah he's a smart
man smart man that peter jackson
the last time we spoke pete uh stephen
you were you were in that
uh uh background with all of your lord
the rings bookcase now you're in a
different
background where do we find this is my
office this is my office
at the uh at the ed sullivan building
at the theater this is the build office
buildings that's here with it this is
this
this everything behind me was um
reproduced for my little storage room
theater my storage room studio that we
had on the eighth floor here we tried to
reproduce this look
right there i've got felt this lovely
cloth felt wallpaper
which is just lovely that's fantastic i
think a lot of people who don't
don't know about late night i've i've
become friendly with with jimmy kimmel
over the years
um but i think a lot that's all i have
time for okay thank you
well done well done but a lot of people
who don't know
late night might assume that you come in
you know half an hour before get your
suit on do the show
but you you guys have a full day at work
before that right could you just talk us
through what a day at work looks like
before the show and everything
yeah um well listen i'll tell you what
sort of the platonic ideal is because
right now we're still in this odd hybrid
situation
between the quarantine and being back
at the theater because not all of my
staff is back all the time because
they we're all scattered to the four
winds for 15 months and they're slowly
coming
they're slowly coming back in we
probably won't all be together till the
fall
um what happens is that uh starting
at lord what is the what is it now
the writers get together at nine for a
little
uh a pre-pitch pitch to each other where
they talk through ideas
they we have a breakdown that gets done
early in the morning so when i wake up
there's a news breakdown of basically
what's being talked about you know all
around the country
some stories are very reasonable mostly
they're they're they're broad news
stories
some more intense some sort of sillier
but i have page after page of a
breakdown and i've gotten one the night
before too
basically like the night before before i
go to bed my executive producer will
have sent out like
hey if nothing else happens by the time
we wake up in the morning if the
national conversation changes in no way
here's six things we could talk about
tomorrow and a lot of those things
basically we try to beat them with a
little bit more currency of what
happened today in the morning my head of
research uh
brandon marianachi who came from real
news we stole from anderson cooper over
at cnn
he has a long breakdown of what like
what
a little bit deeper dives into each of
the stories some of which got sent out
the night before
some are new things that have developed
some of the things that we
events that we know were happening later
in that day you know whether there's
like a press conference or something
like that
and then and yes silly stories too
and then everybody pitches on those at 9
30.
like here's jokes i've got on this idea
and generally speaking between the nine
o'clock show and the 9 30 show
the head writers have corral
i mean the pitch rooms 9a 9am pitch the
930 pitch
the head writers uh jay katzir and ariel
dumas
have corralled those ideas into stories
like
let's tell the story to stephen and the
other executive producers
this is how we see the story being told
today with jokes
and then that goes on for about an hour
at the end of which
i generally leave it to my creative exec
tom purcell he goes these are the six
stories because we usually have six
teams of two writers a piece
and they that switches up all the time
and those those six people
those six teams will go off and write
these six stories
uh four of which might make it into the
show
you know if it if they're big stories
maybe it's like
two might make it into the show because
there's a lot to explicit there's a lot
to
open up on on a story
and i'd say our monologues are a little
different than other people because it's
not so much like a single
like data point in a punch line is that
we basically tell the story of
tell the story of the national
conversation today back to the audience
yeah you know we we tell a little longer
stories than the other guys do
we do a longer monologue i mean last
night i did 15 and a half minutes or
something
generally like they're like eight
they're like eight-minute monologues
classically um so that that mean it goes
on those riders then have an hour and a
half to go get a draft out
i will then go over to our cold team
which is
there's six people we call cole team six
and they work on the cold open of the
show every day there's a new cold open
every day
and they really have a gun to their head
because they have to deliver
something less than a minute that is
about something that happened generally
in the last 24 hours
and then i work with them usually for
half an hour then i do like the business
end of show business where i talk to my
my show runner which is sort of like the
managing executive producer of the show
and he and i talk about well i don't
know business budgets and staffing and
the network and schedules and all that
kind of stuff and i
try to stay involved in that um to a
lesser degree but i don't
i don't want that to just happen without
any input from me
and then that by the time that's over
it's time for me to start talking
to my guest um
of producers the people who are in the
talent
the people who would have interviewed i
don't know who your producer was do you
remember who your producer was
were you guys you're good with names
normally gosh i wish i could remember
two
young ladies two young ladies
uh brunettes ally and and uh
carly was it
was it uh caroline um
was it caroline was it dom hmm
was it dom no no no i wouldn't remember
they were very good
yeah they are they're all very good
anyway so i'll talk with them
billy two out of three men will
experience some form of hair loss
by the time they're 35. well that is a
lot of men tom
and i'll tell you who'll help with that
keeps they have something they keep it
very simple
stress-free and a way to keep your hair
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door
every three months you don't even need
to leave your home and it's low cost
treatments start at just ten dollars a
month and keeps offers
generic versions now you might be
feeling a little self-conscious about
getting that scent in the mail who knows
maybe your neighbors are having a little
lucky loose something like that don't
worry
it's all sent to you in discrete
packaging and they have proven results
and here's the thing dom prevention is
key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results
so you better act fast you're ready to
take action and prevent hair loss go to
k
e e p s dot com slash onion
to receive your first month of treatment
for free that's k
e e p s dot com slash onion to get your
first month free
k e e p s dot com slash
onion tom really if only it was possible
to get a list of great candidates the
moment you post a job online
well dom it is with indeed
instant match the moment you post a
sponsor job
you get quality candidates whose resumes
on
indeed match your sponsored job
description
when hiring gets hard you need indeed
the job
site that makes hiring incredibly simple
just attract
interview and hire in fact with indeed
you can do all your hiring
in one place even the interviewing don't
just hope
your perfect candidate will find you
indeed's hiring tools
help you cut through the noise to hire
faster and smarter
in fact indeed's instant match provides
a list of quality candidates
whose resumes are on indeed the moment
you post
a sponsored job according to talent nest
indeed delivers four
times more hires than all other job
sites combined
join more than three million businesses
worldwide
that use indeed to hire great talent
fast get started right now with a 75
sponsored job credit to upgrade your job
post at indeed.com
onion get a 75 credit at indeed.com
onion indeed.com slash onion
offer valid through september 30th terms
and conditions apply
i'll talk with them about like who are
the guests tonight and what might we
talk about
like have you had a conversation with
them already we'll have the
pre-interview go we'll do a little plan
of like
what order in which i want to talk about
things and then after that it's really
time for me to shower and shave
and get into the old monkey suit and
um i go down to the theater at three
o'clock
and we we um
oh i might in between there i might have
like a field piece or something to look
at i might
go to an edit room or something like
that look at something we're going to
roll into the show
and then give my notes there might be
some questions from the writers or the
editorial level of writing the execs
who've been assembling the script saying
hey it's a it's a bake off between this
idea and that idea
which one is more appealing to you they
might have make some
there might be some production decisions
that have to be made earlier because
if we make changes later in the day
there isn't time
because we're up against this very hard
5 30
time every day yeah you know it's
absolutely the
clock on the wall the hands are spinning
like one of those
meat cutters at a deli just they're just
spinning so fast and you can't go
backwards on any of your decisions
because there won't be any time
to rethink you have to like be able to
make decisions and just live with
whatever that decision was
yeah so sometimes they need to make me
to make a decision
then i do the rehearsal and that then
that's a nice relaxed atmosphere
some of the staff will be in the room
sometimes john baptiste will be there
you know playing the piano listening to
listening sometimes not and uh
i'll just do the whole monologue
generally speaking if i'm hoping to do
between a 13 and a 15 minute monologue
i'll probably do 20 minutes of material
so we have to cut
you know maybe seven minutes out of it
yeah and then there's a second act which
is usually a little long and it's
usually something a little
sillier not as topical maybe conceptual
and then and then we've got the guests
or band or a comic or something like
that and that i don't really think about
again until they're right out there
so right before they come out but there
might be
altogether 25 minutes of material
that i perform wow and i'm in my suit
and i
don't do a full presence
yeah you know i kind of mark it yeah i
get the rhythm of it i might improvise a
little bit to find my own joke get it my
own my own mouth feel as i like to call
it
yeah and then we'll do some of the
rewriting on the fly going i don't
understand that joke what's the
intention here what's that mean
why does this at the same time the cold
team will come in and present the cold
hopefully they have two to make one as
we call it like they give you two
options for today but
sometimes it's just one to make one you
got to make it work sometimes it's fine
other times just a little that takes a
lot of time
because it didn't work you have to have
one so we'll have to grind in the moment
on what is it what will it be what do we
have anything in the hop or anything
that's not topical
generally not and we sometimes that has
to be hammered out
for a long time before we can let them
leave the room
so we know we don't think about it again
yeah yeah and then it'll just be ready
when the show goes up
sometimes i don't see it again until the
audience sees it
and and then we go downstairs
underneath the stage uh where our
rewrite room is
and we rewrite
25 minutes of material in about an hour
which is a very
fast process so
you know you've got about two and a half
minutes for every minute you need to
rewrite
so you're reading it thinking about it
assigning it to
the writers who are upstairs in or in
their
writers room which is way upstairs like
on the 14th floor
so it's like many many many many many
floors away from me
but there's a writer in the room who's
translating it over the internets
to them saying this is what we need
there's a spy cam in the room so
somebody from up
up there can watch us in the room
rewrite so in case we need to like
literally talk to someone immediately
there's screens up there showing us the
graphics on one showing video on the
other
and then there's a whole big screen that
has the script on it
and we run it through this program
called scripto
which is a collaborative script writing
software where everyone in the building
can work on the script at the same time
and everything immediately gets
formatted for every different department
in the way they need it
and all all changes are tracked and we
can time we can time dial through and go
[ __ ] it it was better half an hour ago
and we could literally take it back a
half an hour be right there
wow and we make a lot of changes in a
short period of time i'm sorry this is
such a long answer
oh it's great it's fascinating so we
make a lot of changes in a short period
of time
and then the last thing i do is i i
we make sure we don't have any more tk's
to come
okay with a come with a k right to come
no more tk's or dollar signs we call
them
no more dollar signs in there which
means these are jokes that need to be
replaced or improved right
and then once that's all done then i
read down
the whole script very fast
like i read i read it this fast second
city email is wrong
[Music]
with the machine the short of zero kelly
and the remarkable the calories okay
that's like that that's how fast i might
read a page because i just want to get
the map in my head now
i don't want to perform it i want to
perform it up there yeah i want to get
the map in my head so i'm not really
looking at the screen when i'm
talking i'm actually looking at the lens
yeah and i'm or i'm looking at the
audience i don't want to have to think
where is this joke going or how does
this connect to the next thing so i read
maybe a 15 or 13 minute script down in
two and a half minutes yeah just to get
it in my bones
know where i'm going look ahead you know
look over the mountaintop to the next
valley
of the next joke and then um
and the last thing we might go is like
is there anything we're missing like
there's somebody there the whole time
generally my
my showrunner exec who's along with a
researcher
saying is anything happening right as
we're rewriting this that
is going to consume the conversation
tonight and we don't want to be left out
right wow and with the old guy the old
president
that happened all the time yeah he used
to have like a he'd have like a five
o'clock press conference right and we
would say
[ __ ] it throw out everything
and then we would write we have to go up
at 5 30. so then we would write
a 15 minute monologue in half an hour
from scratch
and that was insane we don't like doing
that anymore well we don't do we don't
do that anymore because it just
the speed has decreased like talk about
heart palpitations
like where our arrhythmia we're back in
a normal human rhythm now
we got grown up and and then and then i
go perform it
somebody comes and knocks on the door
and uh i go out
my assistant says here's where the
guests are
or this guest hasn't arrived i might go
say hi to the guest beforehand
um uh i'm told if there's any like
elaborate proppage
i need to use during the show like where
it is and
how to work it or whatever um i might
get touched up here and make up then i
go upstairs
i shake everyone's hand backstage and i
say
have a good show and anyone who walks
through even if i don't know them they
have to stop and i have to say have a
good show to them
yeah yeah uh because no one's allowed to
be around me without me
without getting that from me
superstition thing stephen is that
yeah i guess so it's superstition and
just sort of positive vibes right right
right
you know because i'm out there to make a
connection with the audience and so i
want to take a moment to actually say
to everybody backstage and mean it have
a good show yeah
because we don't have another shot to do
this material
one of the things that struck me when i
got into television was because i
started in
straight theater and then cabaret comedy
you know improv comedy in a cabaret
setting or sketch comedy
and you do it over and over again every
night and you'd find new nuance or new
way to play it or
or a new relationship with other people
on stage
and then when i started doing tv i was
shocked i was
disheartened it kind of was
heartbreaking where you would do it they
go okay great let's move on i'm like
i never get to do that again that's it
but how could it possibly be as good as
it needs to be
yeah i didn't i didn't just we didn't
rehearse
you know it's tv we ran the lines that's
all we did
so how could this possibly be good but
it's a different headspace right
it's uh yeah it totally is yeah and so i
want to get i want to get in this
um it's like a high wire feeling
i'm going to confidently walk across
this wire in just a moment
and the first thing to do is just tell
everybody have a good show
and to give that out like little candy
backstage make that little connection
the last person i shake my um uh
i guess he's my a2 my sound guy putting
on my uh my pack
shake his hand last and then i slapped
myself in the face
hard twice and i've said this before
this is a revelation
i slap myself in the face hard twice i
take off my glasses to do it so i can
really do it
and i do that hey i do that
because you're a bad boy to be well kind
of to
be in the moment right wake up don't
you're tired
or you're thinking about where you're
going dinner later no
this is it only do this for the next
hour yeah nice and i slap myself in the
face
and i know i've slapped myself hard
enough
if i regret having done it that's
brilliant and that's that's my rule i
have to go like ah that wasn't hard
enough
that didn't really hurt that's a lot of
stuff
over the years it is two a night at
least and then uh
because it's twice each time i just set
some two yeah and then uh
and then john introduces me john
baptiste introduces me i go on stage
take questions from the audience yeah
meow meow meow
i've got to say i've got certain things
that i say to the audience every time
because i want to know how good of an
audience they are
right and i've got a few things that
i mean they're not the greatest jokes in
the world but they're
about the audience and they're about
what's happening exactly in that moment
between us
yeah you know and i know things that
will make an audience laugh right and
and i can gauge from their reaction
how hard i have to work in the first few
minutes of the monologue
because if they're really good i
immediately go out and i just start
riding the wave of their own energy and
i actually leave stage with more energy
than i
want walked on yeah but if they're not
good then you kind of have to staple
them
to your nut sack and drag them over
the finish line of the monologue but
that's the gig you know
doesn't matter but i want to know before
i walk out what it is
and then the last thing i do is i shake
my
stage manager's hand mark mckenna who
i've worked with forever
i shake his hand and i say have a good
show and he says have a good show
and if it's a particularly hard show
like really ambitious
show um or a live show something like
that
uh i'll say uh
you got a stick of demons do you know
that reference no
it's from the right stuff you guys what
you got a stick of beemans oh no demons
is an
old style gum it was this old gummy they
still make it but nobody uses buys it
anymore yeah
beeman's gum and in the right stuff
chuck yeager
who of course is breaking the sound
barrier in galloping
in glamorous glennis um before they drop
him for his rocket ride to try to read
the sound barrier every time he tries
he says to his number two you got a
stick of demons
the guy says i think i might and he goes
well loan me one i'll pay you back
and so mark and i do that on nights when
it's really hard
we did it i did it the first night we
ever worked together wow so we do it
like
before we did like the quarter million
people on the mall
in dc yeah we did it or a live show or
an election night or something like that
right and then we do the show and then
then and then we do the show and
and then after the show's over we do a
postmortem where we say okay how long is
it
did are we on time are we short are we
long what are we doing like if we're
short we run a few extra credits
if we we run full credits and if or we
the band plays longer in the breaks
yeah in the the bumpers we're never
we're never short
we're always long and if we're long we
go well
what beats can be lifted out of a guest
and we don't like and we're not gonna be
brokenhearted right yeah there are times
you just have to take stuff out like
we took a ton out of your we were very
good
but we're like we're we've it's like 20
minutes yeah and we have like 14 what do
we do
yeah yeah so um that discussion happens
and then we say what's happening
tomorrow
who are the guests anything i need to
know is there any is there are we doing
a
a bit with a guest is there a sketch
what do i have to read tonight is there
footage i have to see tonight before
before i go to bed to give you an answer
so in the morning we're ready to you
know
ready to roll without because the
tomorrow is just going to be just as
hungry as today was
and there's no time tomorrow to change
the schedule that i just gave you that
schedule has to be the schedule
right so and then um
when that's it then i go home i take off
my makeup and i go home and that is
probably
that's pushing 11 hours wow
not including tren not including um
uh commute travel and that's on one cup
of coffee you're doing that now
now i'm doing it on one cup of coffee
that's that's very good stephen
billy you and i do a massive amount of
traveling and we go through
airports and we stay in hotels and one
of the things that gives me a lovely bit
of peace of mind
is having my own expressvpn account
exactly tom because when you're on
somebody's wi-fi you're in a hotel
or you're in the airport as you say and
you want to do some online
banking and you're putting in your
passwords you don't want to be doing
that
no not with a vpn you want a nice little
firewall to protect your personal
information you might be having a
private conversation with someone
you might be sending them a script
that's confidential you need to know
that it's safe and with expressvpn they
keep all your information
nice and safe and the great thing about
expressvpn as well
it's rated number one by cnet wired
and the verge love that so secure your
online activity by visiting
expressvpn.com slash onion
today that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash onion and you can get an
extra three months
free expressvpn dot com
slash onion this episode is brought to
you by four sigmatic
a wellness company that is well known
for its delicious mushroom coffee four
sigmatics mushroom coffee is real
organic fair trade single origin
arabica coffee with lion's mane mushroom
for productivity
and chaga mushroom for immune support
i'll tell you what tom
i've been starting my day with four
sigmatic ground mushroom coffee
and instead of taking my regular coffee
i've been doing that in the morning
and i feel a difference more focus maybe
even more creative
oh i love that mushroom coffee is also
easy on the gut so it doesn't leave you
with that awful
jittery feeling or a midday crash now
you're probably thinking dom does it
just taste the mushrooms
it doesn't i can guarantee it tastes
like delicious
coffee yummy yummy so we've worked out
an exclusive offer with four sigmatic on
their best-selling mushroom coffee but
this is just
for the friendship onion listeners get
up to 40
off plus free shipping on mushroom
coffee bundles
to claim this deal you must go to
4sigmatic.com
onion this offer is only for the
friendship on your listeners
and is not available on their regular
website you
save up to 40 and get free shipping so
go right now to
f o u r s i g m a
t i c dot com slash onion and fuel your
productivity
and creativity with some delicious
mushroom coffee
hey stephen after so many years of you
wearing suits for your job do you have
things that you will not accept in a
suit now like it doesn't seem to be that
you wear double-breasted suits do you
have rules i've never like brought
me a double-breasted suit what am i am i
am i am i stepping onto a yacht
am i a commodore why am i wearing a
double brush
it doesn't have does it have epaulettes
then don't make it double-breasted
because you can't have a casual moment
in a double-breasted
suit right if you if you unbutton any of
the buttons you look like you're drunk
yeah yeah so i'm not a double-breasted
fan
i like a two button okay yes i like it i
like a two button
yeah i like a tie that's medium thin
i do a four in hand knot you know one
loop over
and then up yeah you know can you do uh
a bigger knot though do you know a
windsor can i do it can i do a windsor
you want a half windsor double wincher
what do you want
well i just need to know that you can do
it can you tie a bowtie
i was gonna treat spilly house i can tie
a bow tie with my
eyes closed for you yeah it's actually
easier with your eyes closed
i love it i love timing i grew up in
south carolina i grew up in charleston
south carolina
and people actually wear bow ties down
there
i love a bowtie i like it too i think
it's good in the summertime maybe the
garden party or something like that
and how about this stephen obviously
you're well versed in this world as well
if one of your guest
producers comes to you 15 20 minutes
before the show
is about to go on and says this
particular guest is having a nightmare
like they're having
anxiety they're clamming up they're
getting sweaty i don't think this is
going to go
well what skill set do you bring to that
game to
to make them blossom
well i hope i could make them blossom um
i might just i always say hi to the
guests backstage right before they come
on
yeah um but if they're really nervous i
might go to the dressing room
to say hi but that's so rare it so
rarely happens
mostly i find
that my enthusiasm for the guest is
always necessary for the audience to be
enthusiastic
you'd be surprised no matter how nervous
a person is when the audience claps when
they hear their name
boy it really loosens people up
the audience is such a benediction you
know the audience is happy to see them
and laughs at anything they say or is
wrapped attention what they say yeah
people generally loosen up a little bit
and if need be i could just talk for 10
minutes and they could nod
right yeah right i always thought that
would be a nice trick
could i have a guest on and not let them
talk the entire
time well i always had to do that with
dap
i always had to do that with daft punk
because i had them on
we were going to have them on and they
said they wanted to be guests
and they said oh this was a week before
they said oh but they can't talk
right i said brilliant so
but they want to be the guest not a
musical guest like no they don't want to
perform they want to be the guest on the
show
and i said okay i'll take that challenge
and because on the old show we only had
six minute segments
right and so i said i will ask them a
six minute question
and they can just sit there and nod and
that was the plan
something different happened which was
also interesting but that was the plan
that's great i love that hey stephen we
can't have you on
the friendship onion without talking
about lord
of the rings yeah let's do it because
you could
you could i would still be happy to be
here but you would also enjoy it
come on we we have to uh you're
you're well known across the world
as a bit of a lauder rings geek
yes i am i believe uh peter jackson
called me
the king oh of the lord of the rings
geeks
love that he called me the king so i'm
king geek so return of the king here we
are
here we go now you guys you know people
who listen to this
probably know that you stumped me with
dern dingle yeah
you know what i i felt bad about that
yeah he felt bad at dinner
he felt you felt bad i didn't i didn't
even want to stump you
i wanted to ask a question that involved
tree beard
because sure because i love mary and
pippin and tree beard i love that part
of the story yeah
yeah and uh i i accidentally stumped you
but i am getting t-shirts done with dan
dingle on it
to be honest we will send you one we
will say
sure you can get that treated now you've
got durndangle
do you think somewhere in your mind you
knew it or did you just
oh as soon as you said it oh really it
was the right answer oh yeah
that's why i was like oh yes that's the
look on you yes
because i thought his was much harder i
thought his
question was much more difficult come on
shelob
is a much more interesting subject
than what was the name what was the name
of the little hollow
was a dingle is a little a little holler
well
why exactly why like why that would be
an interesting
data point i don't know yeah i was like
oh he's going to ask me he's going to
say
name one of the other ants i'm like
quick beam whatever you know
and why is he called quick beam well why
is he called quick beam
we don't know why is he called quick
beam because the faster he
answered an older end before the older
end had actually finished asking the
question
so it's called quick being nice but
anyway
but that see now i'm just trying to
shore up my reputation
so
[Music]
it was almost like it was hiding in
plain sight because as you said it's
such a
throwaway thing that why would you need
to know that whereas obviously
right you know the stuff about um
she-love is so much more
dynamic right um we want to ask you
another question
no we're not going to well the question
i would like to ask and
i do this with people who obviously over
the years we've met people
who love tolkien and the world that he
created and
and have went on to do music i've met
people who
a wonderful guy casper rife who
who's written music for every poem and
every song in the book
just wonderful people who are just just
love those world
that world you know and i always love to
ask
how how were you introduced to it what
where did you read it first
or who told you about it when my friend
uh i was in i guess i was
12 maybe pushing 13.
so i would have been ill as if seventh
grade
yeah something like that whatever you
call it uh
uh in your schooling system but seventh
grade for us middle school yeah
and a friend of mine keith sargie and i
wrote
i already read a lot of science fiction
i hadn't gotten to fantasy at all but i
had already been reading a ton of
science fiction
yeah like golden age heinlein asimov
arthur c clark yes some silver age stuff
like larry niven
and keith lahmer uh and
he gave me the lord of the rings because
he he
he said you should read this this is
great and
i hadn't read the hobbit yeah and so i
read the lord of the rings first
and i i it set the hook in
so deeply i remember the room i was in
when i
cracked open the the fellowship for the
first time and that artwork because that
it was a mid 70s version of the books
that had
tolkien's original watercolors like of
of uh back end of the hill in the
distance hobbiton and the hill in the
distance
and then the second one the second book
had um i think uh
lothlorien uh it was meant to be fangorn
i think but i think it's actually a
painting of welflorian
and then the third one had baradura
painting of barodarona
all by tolkien and i i
i was completely
entranced i was enchanted i was it was
like i was under a spell
i remember being in the middle of the
second book in the chapter or guy you
guys are being dragged across the plains
of rohan i remember lying on the couch
for the first time reading it
and realized i hadn't been breathing for
like a whole page
yeah and setting up because i was
and i was like as if i had come out of
deep water yeah i
never had and i love reading and i i
always loved reading and i
i read like a book a day but i was so
deeply in this world i was so consumed
it was such like
it was it was such like such like being
transported into another world
that uh it's never let me go there has
never been a point in my life from that
moment that it hasn't been part of my
sort of continuing consciousness now i
read it a bunch when i was in high
school
and um and then maybe didn't read it so
much in
in in college but then i got out of
college and i read it again
and that's really when i didn't stop i
probably was like 24
yeah and i read it and i realized that
aragorn
is the apollonian model of manhood like
the greek ideal
he is great at a lot of different things
but you can't pigeonhole him
he is the perfect model of a man he is
uh he is
a hunter he's a tracker he's a healer
he's a warrior he's a poet yeah
yeah you know he's he's a he's a um
a a a ruler he's a governor he's an
administrator
um um he's a visionary he can see
he has he's far sighted like i remember
thinking oh well that's
as as much as apollo as a as an ideal
for the greeks
uh aragorn is that for
um for me
yeah and of course now the aragorn is
too great for anyone to aspire to the
hobbits really
the hobbits are the best any of us could
possibly get yeah yeah like
the hobbits are us right you know and
that's and and we should be
we should love life as much as they do
right you know
and take the win in the rain and the
suffering with you know grace the way
they do
but aragorn is the model yeah so anyway
that's a long answer your question i
probably is twelve
and keith sarge you gave it to me but no
no i keep talking and then later
and then later i went read the hobbit
right wow i did the opposite
i along i i grew up in a sort of um
uh housing scheme in glasgow
and we just played soccer just played
football that's all the boys did
and one day one of the boys was reading
the hobbit
and we said what's this you know and and
for some reason we all like this group
of like eight
boys all started reading the hobbit at
the same time
and we'd talk about it the next day and
it never
it was never repeated it didn't go on to
the other rings
but there was this month where this
eight or ten boys and crann hill glasgow
all read the hobbit together apart
you know in our own houses reading let's
do two chapters tonight and then we'd
talk about it the next day
and amazing that tolkien
somehow got himself in even that place
and gave me a memory that you know i'll
take to the grave of these
boys just saying oh my can you believe
the dragon came yesterday you know
just unbelievable but when i went to the
lord of rings
and it was um frodo rather than
bilbal that stopped me right there i
wanted
i wanted to read more bilbo and uh so i
never read it so i was
really interested so was there other
friends at that time or was it just you
and this one friend keith uh just me
me and this one friend and then i think
everybody else like um
we started playing this game i mean you
know everybody knows what it is now but
back in the
time nobody knew dungeons and dragons we
were playing dungeons dragons
and and i started playing it
1977 i mean i i actually think it hadn't
been
up until then it had just been a few
small circle of people that knew gary
gygax the guy who created it
right so like the week it arrived in
charleston south carolina me and my
friends started playing it
because we've been playing another game
before that called metamorphosis alpha
which was also created by gigax which is
essentially
dungeons and dragons but in space it was
science fiction it was a science fiction
role-playing game
okay it didn't really take off i don't
know why you guys know it no no really
loves
science fiction based stuff so that's
and i've never played dungeons and
dragons but
if we can get a sci-fi one i meant yeah
i don't know whether you can
well if you like sci-fi have you ever
read heinlein's universe like the story
universe
no just based on it's it's um you really
enjoy it it's really it's a classic it's
it's it's the idea of
there's a colony ship so large
i have read it because that when the
civilization on the ship
falls on its way to alpha centauri or
proxima centauri whatever it is
that the people who continue to live
forget that it's a ship
oh no i haven't and they forget there's
a ship
and and there are parts of the ship that
they're not supposed to go to
which is the the little which we find
out later which are the less
less um uh shielded parts of the ship
from the position
and people go up there basically end up
having generations of mutant children
and so there's the muties the muties who
live closer to the hub of the ship and
then
and the closer you get and it's it's
it's you know centripetal force
you know false gravity the closer you
get to the middle the less you weigh
it freaks people out because what why
why why do you get lighter the closer
you go
and you run into mutants and one person
has the courage to go all the way into
the center
and get to the old captain's quarters
and they go oh my god this is a ship oh
really
and they realize oh we're on a ship they
think it's the whole universe
okay that's what the short story is
called universe and
so metamorphosis alpha is essentially
based on that
where you're on this colony ship that
has
propagated all these mutations that you
have to fight to survive
love it and basically get the ship on
back on course and so it's it
in in some ways it was like a sandbox
the way d d
is but unlike d d it was bounded
yeah in and so it didn't give you
freedom if you're on the ship it was
bounded but it's a really great game
we played that for about a week before d
d came out and then we went oh this is
way better
and then we started playing d and d i
don't think you can get metamorphosed
alpha good luck
let's try and find it we'll get that
book as well yeah but uh
but it's just a short story and then um
and then i played d and d with my
friends
and everybody in the d and d circle
ended up reading tolkien nice
and by the way we say tolkien we don't
say tolkien and i know that's wrong
well no we always say tolkien nothing
you see is wrong
he's always been extremely well spoken
apart from the word licorice which he
says like this
licorice i'm not sure that's correct i
think that's probably
licorice licorice licorice right but
that's all right licorice
yeah um so you might like this stephen
i play d and d during covid lockdown
as a halfling and i saved the day
three or four times in a row for my crew
at one point
i jumped off a roof and in the air
managed to roll a perfect 20
and threw flying stars at these
characters
that were killing my crew on the ground
so mid-air i pulled these flying stars
out of the
out of my back and killed the people
that were attacking them on the ground
were you a havling thief what were you i
was a halfling i was a halfling monk
oh okay yeah it was it was super good
i've never played
i've been trying to get billy to play
for a long time because billy has a
brilliant mind and he's very imaginative
but he is more science fiction based
than anyone else and we did a podcast
that said well if you want to do a
science fiction based podcast there's
almost like a star trek based
dnd and billy almost took his clothes
off
yeah i would do that i would do that do
you have a favorite uh
sci-fi uh uh world or
or arcane of the universe i do universe
cosmology what
i love the star trek universe i think
it's brilliant i love it i agree
i i'm trying to remember the book that i
thought you were talking about
you might help me here a ship comes into
our solar system it's a big ship they
would go up to see where it is there's
nothing there
but then it slowly starts to evolve
into yeah so like um water
comes and then single cells become fish
and
you know and it becomes more it's a it's
brilliant
i'll i'll figure out what it is that was
probably my favorite sci-fi um
experience reading the book it's not
part of the star tied rising series is
it no i don't think so i think there's
only
two books okay i'll i'll remember
to get back to rings for a second when i
i think
that that is sorry well you guys will
love it anyway my
the most heartbroken i've ever been
finishing a book
was lord the rings it's not my favorite
book of all time although it's probably
in the top
three or four books that i've ever read
but when
sam says you know okay well you know i'm
home and that's me and i'm just gonna
kind of
till my garden and when i closed that
book at that point i remember thinking
really like is there no more in that
book that was i
almost didn't finish it because of the
feeling of
heartbreak and my mom my dad read the
book
you know a lot of times and told me when
i was a kid you're not quite ready to
read it yet and then
when i was kind of 14 15 said okay now
you can read it but when my parents came
to visit me in new zealand
my dad had read it multiple times my mom
hadn't and i jokingly said to my mum
mum you can't come to new zealand and
meet
pippin and meet gandalf and meet aragorn
and not know exactly
who these people are you're going to
have to read the book and my mom's
wizards and magic and swords and dragon
i don't want to and i said it's not
it's not that mum it's not that it's
people it's it's about people it's about
characters like all the great books are
and i me i
uh got her to agree to read the first
hundred pages i just said read the first
hundred pages
if you don't like it we'll drop it she
read the first hundred pages
and loved the book and finished it
and was in love with andy circus and and
elijah oh in fact this is a really i
think you know the story
when i was when i was 16
studying drama at college and english
lit
i went into manchester and hung around
outside
theaters hoping to meet working actors
to ask them their advice about how i
could become an actor and all this kind
of stuff
i was outside the palace theater in
manchester
and an actor came out who i recognized
from kind of tv in england
and i said okay can i ask you a question
and and he stopped and said yeah of
course
i said i'm trying to be an actor i'm
studying drama and i don't know what to
do next he said oh well that's great
you're studying drama
he said you know do as many plays as you
can
and try and get involved in regional
theater and then maybe you can do drama
college and that's how it worked for me
and you know good luck to you and all
this kind of stuff signed a little
autograph and walked up
that was andy circus and i only found
that i don't know right
i only found that out about a year into
filming do you remember that yeah
where i said to andy he was in the
makeup trailer with the hobbits chatting
and i was like andy i don't i can't work
this out but i feel like we've met
before maybe it's just because you're an
actor on tv
and suddenly i was like wait did you do
a play
at the palace theatre and we put it
together yeah so he really put me on a
path
to do to become a professional actor and
then years later we're in
the trilogy together crazy stuff
fantastic yeah i love that
well done that was the fantabulous
stephen colbert is that a good
description fanta it's a made-up word
i don't know if it is you know i think
that's in the dictionary fantabulous if
you could uh
have a look for that for us and write
into it john could you look up
fantabulous in the description
um what a lovely
inspiring wonderful chap
yeah and what i mean must be a great
lover of uh books he's read a lot yeah
yeah
i think he's one of those minds isn't he
i love that i love
when he was talking about um not
breathing through a whole page
i mean being able to put your mind so
much into uh
a story wonderful that was a great chat
dog
i wish i'm glad i've actually i don't
think i've ever seen you be so beguiled
certainly by another man when you first
met me it's hard for me
to see you meeting me because i'm having
the moment but probably when you met me
for the first time you were
utterly wowed i was well i didn't sleep
that way in
being the third person watching you
interact with stephen colbert you tickle
pink
i find him absolutely intriguing and
enchanting yeah i think if he were to
just say
it write to you personally on an email
and say hey listen i'm free
thursday night do you want to get dinner
i think you'd jump on a plane to new
york wouldn't you i would i would yeah
if he said to me let's start a podcast
i would leave this one and then go with
it
that's fine john is fantabulous in the
dictionary
could we could we have the definition
and the definition
of fantabulous is
excellent or wonderful now
you've learned something there haven't
you you thought i made up a gibberish
word like
supercalifragilisticexpialidocious but
when did it become a word
does it tell you that in the oxford uh
english dictionary do you know
what the word is to describe the
uh origin and history of a word you know
that that do you know what that word is
no etymology the study of words
no i think you'll find that's the study
of insects
that's entomology thank you
etymology is the study of words
i'm giving it to you because i'm hold on
threatened 1957.
i thought it was a new word i thought it
was new
ish because you'll never see somebody in
a period drama
say for instance downton abbey sounds
and i'll be saying that's fantabulous
oh the uh the place was fantabulous
carlson
he's almost four years her senior it's
absolutely fantabulous
right well anyway what uh what a
fantastic fantabulous episode
with mr stephen colbert and uh
yeah let us know what you think rate
review and subscribe
to our podcast you've got plastic in
your mouth off my water bottle then
if you send us a review because billy
and i do look through the reviews every
so often
it might end up on our social media
pages and every so often it shows up
on the podcast for us to talk about if
you want to email us
it's the friendship onion at
cassmedia.com
or you can send us a voice message at
speak
pipe dot com forward slash the
friendship onion and we will see you
guys
don't forget to rate review and
subscribe
you said that did you yeah i wasn't
listening
to me you are fantabulous
we'll see you guys next week see you
next week toodles